it was always going to be an
uncomfortable morning for the prime
minister
hey boys how are you behind the smiles
and bon ami
european allies are not happy with his
stance on northern ireland
a productive first day but less so today
with the rift over the northern ireland
protocol
showing no sign of narrowing warning
tweets from the heads of european
council and commissions spelling it out
there's no going back on what's already
been agreed and signed off on
the good friday agreement and peace on
the island of ireland are paramount they
said
we negotiated a protocol that preserves
this signed and ratified by the united
kingdom
and european union we want the best
possible relations with the uk
both sides must implement what we agreed
on there is complete
eu unity on this not much rigorous you
might say but the uk is still holding
out for what it calls
a pragmatic compromise the uk throughout
this process has always come
at this uh pragmatically we want to have
a successful trading relationship
with the eu but but the g7 isn't uh you
know it isn't a branch line of the
brexit negotiations it is a
really key international summit
[Laughter]
president biden's come here to rally his
allies instead he's watching them bicker
whatever nice words they find to say
about him it's great to have a
the u.s president part of the club and
are willing to to to cooperate and i
think that
what you what you demonstrate is that
leadership is partnership
the united states i've said before we're
back the us is back
the u.s wants unity most of all on china
and allies to call out its human rights
abuses
on the uyga minority forced labour camps
the separation of families
enforce birth control and torture but
some g7 members
are reluctant still to confront beijing
inside the summit among politicians
there's clearly disunity on northern
ireland
differences of opinion on china outside
people want clear progress
on tackling the threats to their lives
concrete action on covert 19
and saving the planet from climate
change
there will be commitments on tackling
the next pandemic and fighting the
present one we're told
and we're promised initiatives on
climate we want more renewables so that
the children can have
clean power ocean protection kind of
fisheries management
get all the plastic out of the ocean
stuff like that is really really
important
this is a g7 that seems more determined
to work together than recent ones
but it has just tomorrow now to convince
the world it is united
and strong enough to meet the great
challenges of our time
dominic waghorn sky news falmouth